good morning John today I want to talk
about things but I like for example a
community people can come together and
make me buy this ok they can make me
borrow it from a friend but still step
one completed more on that tomorrow
there are all kinds of things that I
like John for example I like when commas
can make things much more awesome here
we have a multi-use power mister but I
also have a green sharpie though I'm
adding a comma
it's multi-use power mister I think it's
important to like stuff you could spend
a lot of time thinking about the things
that we don't like man whether it's you
know the world ending or inequality or
sex in the city we often just accept the
things that we like and complain a lot
about the things that we don't like but
if we could like intensely dwell upon
the really great things in life the way
that we intensely dwell on the negative
things in life I think that would be
fantastic
so in this video I'm going to try to
intensely dwell on things that I like a
great deal which is good because if I
wasn't dwelling on good things I would
be dwelling on taxes because that's what
I'm working on right now and it makes me
wanna die one of my all-time favorite
things in the world and this is gonna
sound weird is three-legged dogs now let
me be clear here I don't like
three-legged dogs because they're
missing a leg and I think that's funny
or something I like to be like a dog
because if I was missing a leg I'd be
like oh well I'm socks when you're
missing a leg slow down I can't walk
that fast I miss it a frickin leg and
dogs no no it's real like a dog is on it
it's exactly the same amount of happy as
a four-legged dog that's why I like
three-legged dogs because they have
taken their three-legged this and they
embrace it and they're like whatever I
just hop on my front leg and I run with
a back legs I really like everything
bagels which is too bad because right
now I can't eat wheat or seeds because
of my colon so like everything bagels
are entirely composed of wheat except
for the parts that are composed of seeds
so that sucks
wait no no positive things I like people
who make funny bikes I saw this one in
Portland Oregon the other day and I was
like I like humorous taxidermy that's
pretty good because Montana's full of
humorous taxidermy actually this shows a
sharp shin Hawk killing a Starling which
is great because starlings are invasive
species I also really like the one young
fledgling musicians try and take on the
music industry through somewhat devious
and do
tactics for example Tom Milsom tomorrow
is trying to fool the iTunes list for
April Fool's Day of course into thinking
that he's the number one top selling
artist in the UK so if you are in the UK
and you got a buck to spare please go
buy Tom's song there's a link in the
sidebar to do it but don't do it until
April 1st I love it when we take on the
system take it on I really really really
like it when there are two different
organizations that are entirely
different in what they do and the kind
of people who they serve but they have
the same acronym yeah
like NWA northwestern airlines so every
time I'm at the airport now welcome to
the NWA counter I'm like I mean the
obvious example is the WWF the World
Wildlife Federation and the WWF the
World Wrestling Federation which is
which is a different thing and I also
very much like it when clever graphic
designers we've got the ridiculousness
but of course what I can't help but
loving more than any of those things is
the awesomeness of nerdfighteria Sunday
Jon told you all to illustrate your
favorite dftba acronym and we got some
amazing ones right here we have darling
fetch the battle ax along with dorks
form the best alliances also don't
forget that bunnies attack dead frogs
teach Borden animists to fish take baths
alone dastardly Flying Tigers battle
asthma and dancing frogs think better
always mixed of course with some tiny
chickens on the brain which I'm afraid
to tell you John is certainly still
battling I haven't talked to him I'm
like hey are you feeling any better and
he's like huh
so that's probably not a yes so thank
you as always for your excellent
pictures if you send any more and
pictures on the Naing are one of my
favorite things in the world so
nerdfighters calm people John I hope all
these wonderful things are making you
feel better I know that I'm not just
like Carrie Bradshaw and I apologize but
but tomorrow I think that I won't be
able to make up for that but everybody
who's not boycotting me where if you
were boycotting you but you aren't
anymore because I've been a good boy
let's talk about some of your favorite
things in the comments John I hope you
feeling better
dftba